alexis poulin et litoria liste alexis
polar bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on le disait
les pauvres s'appauvrissent les riches
s'enrichissent davantage avec la crise
du coc vide cette crise au fond à ce
qu'elle a mis en relief les limites de
notre système économique où elle a
montré que les inégalités ne faisant que
s'accroître et que cette crise accélérer
ce mouvement général d'inégalités pour
la france est bien le calendrier
particulier puisque france stratégie
vient de sortir aujourd'hui son rapport
d'évaluation des mesures fiscales et il
est sans appel la suppression de l' isf
l'instauration de la flat tax a fait que
les plus riches sont davantage enrichi
60% de plus de dividendes qui ont été
versés passant de 14 milliards en 2010
est à plus de 23 milliards en 2018 et
ses dividendes et viennent se sont
concentrées au sein des plus riches
les héros les 0,1 pour cent environ 38
mille ménages ont touché les deux tiers
de cette manne financière tandis que les
0 01 % ont touché le dernier tiers en
2018 alors qu'il ne touchait que à 5e en
2010 est donc on voit bien que les
réformes mises en place par le
gouvernement qui était censé aider
l'économie à rebondir
et bien non fait qu'enrichir les plus
riches qui profitent largement de ces
réformes le rapport de francs stratégie
lui ne peux pas dire si ces réformes là
ont été bénéfiques ou non pour
l'économie mais le politique justement
selon vous est ce qu il a les moyens
d'intervenir pour réguler davantage la
distribution des richesses
oui par la fiscalité notamment et on
voit bien que cette fiscalité qu'on a
voulu aligner avec la fiscalité mondiale
qui crée des inégalités au niveau
mondial et bien en france elle crée
davantage d'inégalités et pas autre
chose
et pourtant bercy continuer veut il veut
aller davantage le plan de relance à 100
milliards et bien 20 milliards sont
d'exonérations fiscales pour les impôts
de productivité des entreprises
on continue dans cette logique même si
nous n'avons pas de visibilité sur
l'impact réel sur l'économie
mais dans le même temps ce choix d'aider
les plus riches n'est pas
avec un choix d'aider les plus pauvres
un rapport de l'insee de 2019 lui
faisait état de plus de 1.5 millions de
citoyens français passant sous le seuil
de pauvreté entre 2017 et 2018 et pour
cela très peu dead seulement 0 8% du
plan de relance un est consacré à
l'extrême pauvreté environ 800 millions
d'euros 600 millions d'euros qui sont
pour les tickets restaurant à 1 euro et
pour les aides à la rentrée scolaire 100
millions d'euros pour l'hébergement
d'urgence des plus démunis et puis 100
millions d'euros de l'aide aux
associations donc le politique préfère
démissionner et chargé les associations
de gérer l'extrême pauvreté
victime de des politiques choisies en
fait de la pauvreté et sur quels
ressorts on pourrait s'appuyer
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que nous a appris
cette crise au fond mais cette crise
nous a appris une chose c'est que nos
sociétés développées ont su organiser au
fil du temps la solidarité c'est ce qui
a permis à la france de supporter la
crise financière de 2008 mieux que
certaines autres économies européennes
mais comme l'économie est maintenant le
seul objectif un des politiques
alors il fallait redevenir compétitif
donc enlever les solidarités qui coûte
cher qu'ils coûtent trop cher elles sont
vues comme des externalités négatives
or cet investissement aujourd'hui ceux
qui souffrent le plus de cette crise
sanitaire ceux qui vont souffrir le plus
ce sont les plus jeunes à la fois par
rapport à l'accès à l'éducation de plus
en plus difficile et puis l'accession à
l'emploi rendu également de plus en plus
difficile puisque le marché de l'emploi
va se contracter et que ce sont les
premiers à sortir puisque il n'ya pas
pour eux l'emploi nécessaire donc si on
n'investit pas aujourd'hui sur les plus
jeunes les plus précaires les plus
démunis et bien l'avenir risque d'être
extrêmement difficile parce que ça ne
peut pas tenir une société où les
inégalités sont elles je suis désolé à
un moment les personnes ne peuvent plus
accepter une telle différence de
traitement entre les ultra riches et les
ultras pauvre et c'est les solidarités
aujourd'hui qu'il faut retravailler au
niveau du politique
un avenir extrêmement difficile ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire des mouvements
sociaux très dur à l'avenir oui des
mouvements sociaux très dur un rejet
total du
du jeu politique même démocratique en
disant si les élus continuent de faire
toujours la même politique en direction
des 1% les plus riches des 0 1% des plus
riches alors vous avez le taux
d'abstention déjà qui est énorme
on est presque passé à un suffrage
censitaire voiliers qui se déplacent
pour voter ce sont déjà plus les plus
précaires ou les plus pauvres ceux là
ont abandonné ce jeu là mais derrière le
coup de la pauvreté est beaucoup plus
important que si on arrêtait des mesures
pour enrayer l'extrême pauvreté et on ne
peut pas compter seulement sur les
associations pour cela il ya bien
entendu l'éducation nationale mais il ya
les impôts les riches doivent payer des
impôts
c'est ce qui est demandé par plusieurs
milliardaires américains parce que si on
continue dans cette voie là et bien nous
serons au niveau des états unis le
système de santé système de santé
américain ou si vous n'avez pas de
mutuelle ou d'assurances privées vous
payer une fortune pour vous faire
soigner ou être pris en charge ne serait
ce que pour le corps un virus en france
nous avons des solidarités elles sont
précieuses mais malheureusement le
personnel politique depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années n'a eu de cesse que de
casser ce système de solidarité les
riches doivent payer des impôts et les
solidarités doivent être protégés à tout
prix si nous voulons éviter la
catastrophe sociale
merci beaucoup alexis poulain je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes